hello good morning everyone you can see
that we are a subcommittee of
two our numbers have been uh reduced but
nonetheless representative Gibbons and I
are here I'm representative Peter
Petrino from Milford and I serve as the
clerk on children and family law and I
made the interim study motion uh for uh
this house bill that we're looking at
House Bill
1269 uh representative Gibbons you want
to just say a quick hello hi I'm
representative Gibbons from Manchester
and I guess I'm the sub the co-chair of
the subcommittee of
two there we go well House Bill 12 69 uh
which was um the sponsor was
representative MCU from from meramac
called for um Visual and auditory
recordings of uh the use of restraint
and seclusions for students who have
IEPs and uh personally I found that
somewhat problematic because the way uh
it was proposed to me it seemed like
there'd have to be uh video cameras in
every single classroom uh in every
school throughout the state which I felt
was somewhat of an invasion of privacy
not to mention uh incredibly costly but
listening to the concerns of parents who
testified uh it was heartfelt and I
thought that it deserved uh some further
uh attention so um last time we met was
on September 4th and we had Miss Moren
Tracy who was a disability and civil
rights uh Advocate from marac New
Hampshire and she spoke uh to us
um about um the use of cameras she
thinks uh for accountability purposes
but also she made reference to a law in
Maine which also deals with this issue
previously I thought there wasn't really
much difference between uh the main
statute and and what we have here in New
Hampshire but upon further um
investigation the the statute in Maine
clearly prohibits uh the use of
restraint and seclusion and and uh it
says here that um a cover entity that
receives state or federal assistance may
not subject a student to unlawful
seclusion or restraint this is the main
legislation uh
statute and they Define um seclusion or
restraint to mean unlawful seclusion or
restraint to mean simply seclusion
mechanical restraint chemical restraint
physical restraint or physical escorting
a student that might um be be a risk to
their uh to their health and safety now
here in New Hampshire our statute does
permit uh for limited use of restraint
and so there's the big difference is
that New Hampshire does allow for it but
it is
limited and uh what is prohibited in New
Hampshire is the dangerous uh restraint
techniques so there we have some some
differences um in our discussion last
time uh there was um one suggestion that
uh possibly body cameras be used uh it
was representative Gibbons who
acknowledg that uh it would have to be
something that someone would turn on and
in the event of um something that's
happening that's you know quite
emotional and out of control uh the
individual may not remember to put the
body camera on so that was somewhat
problematic if I
recall let me go ahead I just want to
interject I think it was in I don't want
to I don't want to put words incorrectly
in the in people's mouths but I think it
might have been rep D Simone who thought
that th this might be a cost-saving
effort um if they wore the body cameras
my concern was like if people would
forget like like rep uh Peto mentioned
that they that there's just so much
going on in the moment that they might
forget to turn it on or if they just
don't want to be held accountable then
they might maliciously not turn it on so
either one of those situations and and
it would be impossible to tell which one
um because we can't get inside other
people's minds so like did they forget
or did they purposefully not turn it on
no way to to ever know that exactly
exactly uh representative Nelson uh said
that her research showed that three
states do use surveillance cameras but
only in special ed classrooms and she
had said that four other states had
bills uh however they did not pass and
then of course there was the concern
about funding representative Nelson
mentioned that Texas in particular based
on her research has been using federal
funds uh in Grants for surveillance
cameras
there um all of that being said we uh
adjourned because we were anxious to
view a
documentary uh which some of us did see
this past Monday uh the 23rd uh the
documentary titled the kids we lose and
that was from the lives uh
inbalance which uh is um Dr Ross Green
who's the founder and director of uh uh
the lives and balance and and the
documentary really just uh focused on a
number of uh young children with
behavioral challenges which was a
struggle not only for them but for the
parents and for the Educators and staff
and how uh typically these children are
restrained and secluded in such ways
that are considered to be brutal and
inhumane so Dr um Green's approach um he
calls it a collaborative proactive
solution CPS that his uh group lives in
the balance is promoting as a way of
educating uh trainer uh educate excuse
me to train
Educators so there were a lot of
questions that had after I wish we had
more of the panel here who who who saw
it because I like to get their
Impressions the documentary was hotf
felt but it did not really focus in on
how to address it it just focused on
what the problem was I would have liked
to have seen um Dr Green's uh approach
utilized I'd like to see some data to
see how effective it is in the panel
discussion there was talk about other
evidence-based uh methodologies that
could be used but those other uh
programs were not identified so I do
have a lot of questions in that regard
uh but definitely it's something for us
to explore
further so let's
see so going
forward what I what I see basically are
we can continue with the New Hampshire
statute which would allow for The
Limited use with some cameras maybe in
designated seclusion areas as one
possibility but definitely with teacher
training that's one option or another
option might be to consider what Maine
has done and that would be to completely
prohibit um restraint and seclusion but
again with um with uh significant
teacher
training um training doesn't have to be
in work uh in in in-house workshops at
school districts I was thinking that
this might be something that even the
colleges could apply uh in their teacher
training programs maybe it could be
something that could be put into a
certification
requirements uh but clearly we need some
data as the effectiveness of these
programs because otherwise we're just
taking a shot in the dock so some talk
about maybe a trial program uh have a
school district incorporate uh the
methodologies of uh Dr Green or some
other alternative method apply them see
if they are in fact uh
effective and uh we're also waiting to
hear back from the office of child
advocate because I believe they may also
have some proposals for us to to
consider as well
so basically in conclusion that those
are my observations and we've done you
know we've looked at this in great
detail and um we're just going to have
to wait and see whether or not we're
going to file some legislation and
that's pretty much where we're at so a
long summation on my part and um do you
have anything to
add well we always want to erir on doing
the least harm you know so we don't want
to do any harm um I
personally always prefer not oh yay r d
Simon is here um I always prefer less
restrictive
means um and and training so you know
what whoever was I I don't remember who
was at the mic uh at the last uh
Committee subcommittee hearing that we
had uh but she was mentioning that they
they often will take like try to model a
medical approach and most medical
facilities will encourage the least
restrictive means possible and only do
restraining if it's like incredible
necessary and get them out of restraints
as soon as possible um and we'll also
train staff on deescalation
techniques uh some some hospitals call
it Moab uh management of aggressive
behavior uh so I would always favor that
before just restraining somebody because
someone can get hurt when you try to
restrain someone whether the staff
person or the um in this case student
um and also it can it can up aggressive
behavior you know if you try to imagine
your self in restraints of any kind your
your natural uh inner psyche wants to
get out of that so um so something that
could maybe have been managed by talking
to them it now becomes talking to them
and trying them trying to get out of
their strain itself so that being said
you know these are students who are at
risk so
uh the best solution is always
prevention always so
um but but when you get to the point of
no return like sometimes you do have to
restrain so I'm a little bit torn on I
also I don't also don't favor doing
something without data cuz then you're
technically experimenting on humans so
so um um I do have share the same
concerns that you brought up where where
the research just kind of tell
identifies the problem but doesn't
identify a solution so but repd Simone
is here so so let's uh get her opinions
absolutely absolutely so again the New
Hampshire statute uh does allow for the
proper uses of restraint and that's part
of the language in the U the RSA but
that what is prohibited uh is any type
of restraint which is d dangerous and
there may be times when a situation
happens and there needs to be immediate
action so we're not really sure about a
complete prohibition it's a very
delicate matter but uh rep DeSimone you
attended the um documentary and do you
have any thoughts u based on what you
saw thank you Mr chairman and I
apologize for being late there
was dead stop traffic on the
highway I I so I do apologize for that
and I apologize to the people who came
here
um unfortunately we're in a situation
where um in in representative Gibbons is
aware of it in the on the medical end in
the
hospitals uh where uh people have mental
health issues
that create a a scenario where they
would have to be
restrained the RSA was carefully
constructed to say the word
proper instead of being specific in the
type it said proper
restraint so the people who are involved
in the actual action that is going to
constitute um any restraints being used
are the ones who have to discern what is
and is not proper at that time and I
think that those people need
guidance to figure that out um everybody
in a situation where restraints are
going to be used uh as the documentary
talked about and as I have seen per on a
personal
level uh everybody's
um demeanor is
heightened they want to quell the
situation as soon as humanly possible
without anybody getting
hurt you the use of
restraints unfortunately are a necessary
evil so we have to make sure that we
take the as much of the evil out of it
we have to make sure that the people who
are going to be making the decision as
to whether to restrain or not and whatp
type of restraint will be
used are well
Tred that there is more than one person
available in that
scenario and the types of restraints are
available sometimes a seclusion room is
all that's
necessary sometimes that's not the case
so we have to be very careful with this
legislation and I am absolutely 100%
open to listening to all scenarios with
this legislation that will be coming
forward I'm
sure in the best interest of
first the
child the committee of children and
family law was named appropriately
because
children in my mind come
first uh we have to be sure that those
children are as safe as humanly possible
and sometimes it takes Extreme Measures
to do that so I'm looking forward to
some very good comprehensive legislation
that's going to protect these
kids uh and secondarily protect protect
the people who are trying to protect
these kids uh let's face it they get
kicked they get bit they get
hit the child may not mean to do that
but in the throws of whatever is
happening accidents happen so we need to
help these people be as well Tred as
possible to do their job in the best
interest of that
child thank thank you very much I
thought that was well said uh speaking
only for myself at the moment I'm
currently leaning towards our current
statute which does allow for some
limited uh use of restraint and
seclusion uh amending it possibly for
cameras only in seclusion areas
designated in seclusion areas rather
than throughout the entire uh school and
definitely uh a focus us on teacher
training uh possibly a pilot program
using uh Dr Green's methodology or other
evidence-based methods gather the data
to see if it's effective and then look
for ways that we can start to
incorporate that and teacher training
programs and throughout uh school
districts um I think that would be most
appropriate but that being said I'm
still waiting to hear back from the
office of the child advocate and their
recommendations
but that's where I'm at at the moment
and as always we welcome more input
because the more input we have my mind
is always open to to shifting my
thoughts and my thinking on any matter
so please um you know uh assist us as we
all work together to do our best because
clearly this is a big problem and we
want to get it right so thank you very
much do we have any questions or
comments I say see a hand come on down
at the film also with some of you um
with Dr Green's methodology I just
wanted to provide a little bit of
information to the committee um I think
that you've really identified some
important areas to focus on in terms of
evidence-based interventions and
training that could be made available to
teachers to try to reduce the use of
restraint um as an intervention and also
seclusion um one of the things that
struck me about what little we learned
about Dr Green's intervention because we
didn't learn a whole lot did we on
Monday but what I what I took away from
it was this concept that um what needs
to happen is that the
Educators um and it's not just Educators
because you know we have children who
are restrained in facilities as well and
other programs so it's recognizing where
a child is struggling to meet
expectations and not let that behavior
and then teach them and work with them
before their behaviors escalate so I
think the example they gave was you know
a child who's you know can't has a hard
time come with the classroom rules or
with learning to read you try to do the
intervention early so that seemed like
that was that was my takeaway about what
his methodology without without really
any real knowledge of it what I thought
it seemed like I just wanted to clarify
a couple things for the committee and
tell you where I think there might be um
additional areas to focus on going
forward
um New Hampshire law does prohibit
restraint except in it's an emergency
intervention so um and and and Main law
actually does not is pretty similar so
in in terms of when it's prohibited and
what our current law says is that it's
only to be used to ensure the immediate
physical safety of persons when there is
a substantial and imminent risk of
serious bodily harm to the child or
others and this I'm looking at RSA 126 U
um colon 5 it also talks about how um
the determination should be made um and
I and that it should be only used by
trained Personnel using Extreme Caution
when all other interventions have failed
or been deemed inappropriate so um but
the the challenge though is that we know
restraint still happens we have this
black letter law which limits the use of
restraint to extreme emergency
situations but we see reports like they
come out like November 1st every year
you'll get a report from the Department
of Education and then from DHHS which
all it does though is summarize the
numbers of restraints that have occurred
that have been reported to them there's
really no Deep dive particularly from
the education side into whether these
restraints were proper whether the
people were in fact trained whether
other Alternatives were considered and
the department of of education has had
pretty much a hands-off approach to this
except for just collecting and Reporting
the data so another um strategy that
this committee might consider is either
is maybe um creating a position at the
office of the child advocate or some
other agency I think probably the OCA
would make sense because they work with
children who um all children not just
children who have IEPs this this
restraint law applies to all children
not just with IEPs but to have some
agency in the same way that OCA looks at
restraints that occur in facilities to
have them examine um restraints when
there are patterns that are coming
forward when we're seeing like high
numbers in a particular school for
example um that doesn't have a high CH
you know child population um and and
making some recommendations there and
spot checking so that would be one area
I mean for you all to consider um and
another would be what kind of REM ities
are available or investigations happen
when there is when there are allegations
that a child has been restrained
improperly So currently under current
law there is a um requirement that the
Department of Education and DHHS have a
complaint process and promulgate rules
for that um it it's it's not hugely
prescriptive and it's just an
investigation and there aren't reporting
requirements so it's unclear whether
parents have a right to see the um
outcome whether the outcomes of these
all we know when all we get reported to
us is that there has been a complaint
and it's been resolved so we don't know
whether the resolution is there was a
problem that was identified and the and
the teacher school district is now under
a corrective action plan does that even
happen there's not a lot of information
out there so another area to focus on
and I don't have all the answers would
be to look at what is what is the
complaint process how can we use the
complaint process to do two things one
um make sure that you know if a child is
subjected to a restraint that's improper
how to make that child whole you know
they might need counseling they might
need other supports there may be other
remedies um that I think are allowable
under current law but also how to ensure
that it doesn't happen again and that
teachers receive the training that they
need um that that you know if
administrators need to be involved that
they are involved um but maybe look at
that aspect of our law also to hopefully
make that a little more robust so that
we can learn something from it going
forward so that's my more than two
sons well that was excellent I
appreciate it thank you very
much any questions well no I just wanted
to to feedback just everything they
bringing up is very valid um from my
experience like in the impatient side um
we're always supposed to use the least
restrictive like I was saying and
and get them out as soon as possible and
train staff on proper usage and and
things like that
so um and like I was saying earlier like
deescalation techniques and early
intervention is is critical um in the
hospital setting so everything you're
bringing up here is extremely valid and
I would be on board with it
so okay thank you so much for your time
and attention it's really important
thank
you representative
thison thank you representative and and
for all the people out here I I was at
an event over the weekend and uh uh
couple of the people there were
Educators one of whom was a principal in
another
state in a prompted conversation about
how life was 400 years ago when I was in
school
and when these people became Educators
and then principls and they now
retired and we
have a long way to go in making sure
that these kids kept
safe but we've come a long way and it
prompted memories of when I was in
school and how when you were sent to the
principal's office on the wall
legitimately you may
remember there were paddles of all
different sizes and those were
used by
administrators and so forth and so
on um and I
remember that hanging on one of the
administrators you're going to gasp I
know coat rack was a straight jacket
so if you were totally out of
control you were put in the straight
jacket and you were sat in a chair in
the principal's office and you were not
allowed to move for x amount of
time um I'm really glad that those
practices don't take place anymore um
but I do remember my younger brother
when he was in the second
grade came to my classroom I was in the
fifth
grade and he said to the teacher who was
a very large
man tall and and large and he said
excuse
me my teacher wants to see my sister and
the teacher ignored
him and my brother was just this little
guy and I'll never forget it because it
was on December 10th which was his
birthday and the teacher he said it a
second time he said it a third time he
said it a fourth time and the teacher
just ignored him
finally second grade remember he turned
and said hey
Fatso my teacher wants to see my
sister which at that point he got up
picked my brother up physically walked
out into the hallway shoved my brother
in a locker shot and locked the
door this this was a practice that was
common back in that
time this was in '
67 it was very common I'm thrilled that
it's never used I got into trouble
because I went to the desk and I pulled
the key out of his drawer unlocked the
locker and took my brother out and we
left the school and went
home
um but the point is
I want in my heart of hearts to believe
that that doesn't happen anymore I pray
with all my heart it doesn't happen
anymore and I do know we've come a long
way and I do know we have a long way to
go so I I I applaud everybody who has
become involved in this uh and and the
principles that I spoke with were were
saying y yeah that happened all the time
and blah blah blah blah blah you know it
was it's just crazy
crazy however we have to remember that
that's how parents
were so the school was only doing what
parents did at home and we still have
parents who are doing that at home so we
have to be very careful to understand
where these children come from why
what's happening to them is happening
why what they're doing is happening and
the good news is I just spoke to my
nephew on the way here blue
tooth and at at um
Pinkerton School District they're
opening uh they're building a new
building and most of that building is
going to be in use for children who have
uh a variety of learning disabilities
even to the point where there's going to
be a portion that's going to be built
it's going to look like an
apartment so that when the kids go into
this area they're taught life
skills and there's an observation desk
where the teachers and administrative
staff can observe these kids so again I
we've taken Leaps and Bounds and I'm
very excited to see how that particular
program um evolves in dairy uh it's it's
sounding like a fabulous my nephew has
uh his uh oldest daughter has um a
learning disability and he's very
excited he's been involved in looking at
the pilot programs and so forth so again
please know that we're working we're
working really really hard we're going
to get this done we're going to get it
done I believe in the best interest of
those
children thank you representative and
thank goodness corporal punishment is
now uh outlawed in Most states in this
country which is a very good thing your
story actually made me recall a
situation that happened to me back in
first grade and I'm not sure if I should
put it on the record but it's a somewhat
funny story where apparently I got in
trouble and I don't recall what it was
that I did but the teacher decided to
bring me into the side room uh where the
paddle was and when we got in there she
said you know Peter I really don't want
to paddle you but I can't let the other
kids know that I didn't so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to get the
paddle and I'm going to hit the desk
over here so they can hear the impact
and you're going to Fain that you're
being hurt and when you walk back into
the classroom I want you to rub your
bottom like it really hurt and um I was
like that's a pretty good
deal so that's what happened and here I
was seven years old you know and I
walked back into the classroom rubbing
my bottom and all my classmates looked
in horror and uh that was that was the
story back then so I didn't get
spanked thank you thing but anyways
that's where we're at any other comments
or thoughts yes come on
down uh good morning Mr chair and
members of the committee thank you for
allowing me to speak with you today uh
for the record I'm Becky Wilson I am the
director of governmental relations for
the New Hampshire school boards
Association prior to my work uh at the
school boards which I've been in for the
last 5 years or so I served as a special
education director um in the local
public District here in New Hampshire so
uh this issue is certainly something
that is near and dear to our hearts both
as uh Educators and also as local school
boards I just wanted to be sure that you
had the most current information to work
off of as you decide whether or not to
move forward with further legislation in
this area um in the 22 and 23 uh
legislative session there were two bills
that were passed that significantly
updated the restraint and seclusion law
here in New Hampshire and that was
Senate Bill 179 and House Bill 491 those
were both effective in the summer and
fall of 23 um they significantly updated
the reporting requirements for
restraints and seclusions for uh Public
Schools public charter schools public
acmy and approved non-public schools
there is a 13 page um reporting form
that needs to be filled out by local
public schools or any of those schools I
just mentioned anytime there is a use of
restraint and seclusion it is very
detailed um it goes through every staff
member that was involved what their
training was prior to the restraint uh
any injuries that might have occurred uh
identifies a co-regulator for the
student a person that the student picks
um to help them through the process as
they're being deescalate that is based
off of the students perception of that
person being a positive person in their
life um it talks about what kinds of
programming the school district has um
used to train staff in those kinds of
things um and a lot of that work that
you mentioned previously that was part
of the film that you watched um Dr
Cassie yakle has worked with a number of
districts in this state on uh
trauma-formed practices and working on
those things as a entire District so not
just staff that are working with
students who maybe have a propensity to
need more just deescalation but with all
students um the department of Ed the
office of Social and emotional Wellness
could give you a list of what districts
have worked with uh the department and
what kinds of programs or expertise in
that area that they've been working on
that's been going on for several years
um so I just wanted to make sure that
you knew when you get those restraint
and seclusion reports from the
Department of Ed that has simply just
the school and the number of restraints
and seclusions there is context
obviously that goes with that report um
we have schools again I think as
representative D Simone was just
mentioning that potentially have
targeted programs within a certain
building that addresses students who
potentially are disregulated more often
than others so those numbers may look
higher on a piece of paper um it doesn't
necessarily mean that it's because the
staff is more likely to restrain
students or seclude students it could be
um that they just have a higher
population of students who tend to be
disregulated more often and need more
deescalation so there's a lot of context
within that uh so as you decide whether
or not to move forward with further
legislation I just wanted to make sure
that you knew that uh that information
is available on the department of Ed
website their technical advisory about
the restraint and seclusion Report Form
um how it needs to be completed Etc um
and really detailed descriptions of what
counts as a restraint or seclusion here
in the state and I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you very much I
appreciate that information do you
happen to have uh any uh thoughts about
uh moving forward beyond the legislation
that you just mentioned um thank you for
the question uh I prior to working in a
public District very long ago um in the
late 80s and early 90s I worked in a
residential treatment facility for
students with neurobehavioral disorders
um and I think as representative D
Simone had mentioned things have changed
quite a bit um over the last 30 years or
so in terms of people's perceptions of
restraint and seclusion and when to use
it and when not to the new the law the
way that it is written now is very clear
about um when to intervene physically
with a student in terms of what is
considered imminent harm or imminent
danger to other students as well um I
think you it would benefit the greater
committee potentially to look at um some
of the challenges that I think you
probably saw reflected in the film of
public schools or you trying to figure
out what is the right what is the best
way to create a climate in which all
students feel they belong in our public
schools and all students are accepted in
that way um because I think and again
this is my person this has nothing to do
with the school boards Association this
is my own personal belief but uh when
kids are broken and feeling like they
don't belong that is when you start to
you it it doesn't help the situation at
all so I think the more you can create
communities where everyone belongs the
more of the less chance you have of
students feeling um you know that they
that they don't have a way to regulate
themselves you have some people sitting
behind me who work in a variety of
public schools and non-public school
settings who are very experienced in uh
trying to help students learn better
coping mechanisms and better ways to
manage uh but it really is a whole
district and a whole school approach it
is not about
individual um Behavior plans in the way
that it used to be in the past where
people would certainly just write a
behavior plan um which was about how the
students were going to change and not
about how other people in that person's
life could change change to help the
student also change that's my personal
statement that is not on behalf of the
School Board Association very good yes
and as a former High School teacher of
40 years I fully agree with you that
school has to be a place where every
student feels valued and welcome it
needs to be a safe place the legislation
before us that has us here right now
calls for the use of surveillance
cameras for students with IEPs now of
course students with IEPs are
mainstreamed so my thinking is you'd
have to have cameras in every single
classroom throughout the buildings of
every school what are your thoughts
about surveillance cameras that was the
legislation that's before us thank you
for the question and just to clarify too
I think there was some discussion
earlier about Hospital settings but the
original bill that was proposed was
simply just for public schools correct
so uh local public districts already
have audio surveillance in some areas of
their schools as well as school buses to
some extent um every school board has to
have a policy about their surveillance
and how that is maintained um how long
is the record kept who can see the
record is it part of 91a Etc um this
would expand that quite a bit for local
public districts there certainly would
be a fiscal impact at the local level in
terms of trying to figure out um what
technology would be needed to what
extent um if you take the current law as
it is and people are using restraint in
those situations that are of imminent
danger um it would be difficult I I
think to think about how to manage that
in terms of it being on or off at a
given time I think in theory it would
just be on all of the time um I do share
the concern that I think that that might
be um something that would not be
tenable for a lot of local school
districts in terms of trying to just
maintain that level of surveillance for
lots of reasons technology access um
storage of that data what happens to the
data you're recording everyone not just
those students necess necessarily um and
if students are being included in the
least restrictive environment to the
maximum extent that is appropriate for
them um a place like Pinkerton Academy I
mean that's a very large campus that
would Rec I don't know how you
necessarily would do it in that
particular way I can understand the
people's concern um and the committee's
concern about ensuring that anyone
participating in a restraint or
seclusion are doing that with Fidelity
to the law as it is currently written
and that there is a situation that
involves imminent danger and that those
people are are trained
um I I don't I don't necessarily see
that there is the abil that local public
districts or any of the people mentioned
in this current law so that would be
public academies non-public schools any
School charter schools would have the
ability necessarily to implement that at
the level at which people would feel it
was meeting the spirit of this law or
this Bill thank you very much we have a
question question from um I just wanted
to clarify um we know that that we're
not that this that this legislation
wouldn't infiltrate hospitals we know
that that it's only for the the schools
the reason why we were bringing up what
the hospitals do in the medical setting
um is because there was another Advocate
who mentioned that they like to look at
what the hospitals are doing be and then
not really deviate very far from that
because the hospitals are already basing
it on studies and things like that so
kind of like mimicking so to speak um
but we know that this legislation
wouldn't affect the hospitals so thank
you for the clarification representative
I appreciate it anything
further representative yes thank you um
so to that end concerning the
surveillance cameras um I personally
have a problem with a surveillance
camera in a classroom surveilling every
single student every single moment of
every single day
however I also have a problem
with a child
who is in distress at any given time no
actual log of what created that child
stress what was done
immediately prior to during and after
the incident so I I do think
that cameras should be available and
that was one of the reasons that I
brought up the discussion of um body
cameras for a teacher who may need
something like that again the
schools are restrict red
financially in many
ways but I think we need to be very
careful as to um being able to document
exactly what happens during a particular
incident so can you maybe give me some
thoughts about body cameras as opposed
to surveillance cameras thank you for
the question representative I do want to
point out on the um report that needs to
be filed on every incident of restraint
and seclusion by any of those entities I
mentioned previously there are three
pages that talk about what led to the
incident of restraint and reclusion um
there's a documented um you have to
document what interventions or
deescalation techniques happened prior
to needing to use a restraint or
seclusion there's interventions um
listed that you can pick from that
people need to be trained in prior to
there's a narrative of the justification
of why you used it um and what what you
might do differently uh whether or not a
child's behavior intervention plan has
been modified as a result of this
incident and if so when all the all so
those pieces that you're asking in terms
of um detailed information about an
incident of restraint and seclusion is
available to the people that serve on
that child's um intervention team and to
families so I just wanted to put your
mind at e that some of that information
that you're asking I believe is
available through these forms I don't
know if that it's obviously not public
publicly available because it is
specific to a child um but for people
who sit on that child's team um it's a
very detailed form so anytime there was
a restraint or seclusion um this form
would need to be documented and it's
also filled and filed at the Department
of Education so there is some of that
information out there um you know I
don't I don't want to speak to uh
individual local districts comfort with
body cameras or individual cameras there
are some
districts who may have a uh calm down
area or seclusion room for lack of a
better term um most places are getting
away from that to be perfectly honest um
I think you would find that there's a
number of places in the state including
residential uh treatment facilities and
schools that serve very high need
populations who don't have those areas
anymore they just manage the
deescalation in whatever environment the
child is in um so I can't speak to sort
of what people's Comfort are with
individual body cameras per se um in
those situations but I think if you're
looking for reassurance that there's
some sort of documentation of what is
happening what has led to it what
happened after that that may be
available to you through some of these
report forms that are already out there
um I don't know what how people would
feel individually or at individual
districts about body cameras per se
repres of Gibbons yeah I just I was just
wondering is there do you know if
there's a report filled out for every
time I know there's supposed to be a
report filled out for every time that uh
a restraint is used but are the are the
school districts actually doing that
thank you for the question it's
mandatory and there was an extensive
amount of training that happened in 2023
when these were updated because uh there
was a lot of confusion about what needed
to be reported so if you simply hold a
child's hand is that considered a
restraint because you're restricting
movement per se so there was a lot of
training that happened because initially
when these changes went through the
department was getting a high amount of
reports because districts were reporting
everything um so to make sure that
people understood what was truly
considered a restraint versus what was
not was clarified by the department of
Ed they put out a technical
advisory um on September 5 th of 23 to
really clarify that but yes those
reports are filed at the Department of
Education um and there are ways for the
Department to follow up on that if they
for any reason feel that that's not
happening or if there's any complaint
from a family um or student that felt
that maybe that wasn't being done that
there are ways for that to be remedied
through the
department thank you very much you're
welcome thank you any other comments or
thoughts from from those uh in
attendance
thank you very
much am I on now okay thank you
Representatives um my name is Jessica
Brown I'm the director of student
services at sa67 which is Bo and
Dunbarton um I thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you today um I
do think that talking about the
surveillance cameras is the primary
focus of the legislation as you brought
up but I just first wanted to thank you
for
um considering the fact that the that
these um restraints and seclusions do
sometimes need to occur in these
emergency situations one of the things
that local school districts are tasks
with doing most importantly is keeping
all of our kids in our Public Schools um
that is the um sort of the sentiment
behind Ida right is the least
restrictive environment and being able
to have all options available to us to
be able to keep some of our high needs
kids in our Public Schools is really
important um and knowing that a lot of
the proactive strategies you're looking
at evidence-based solutions to staying
out of restraints and seclusions are
things that school districts are doing
um and trying to make sure that we have
less of those experiences for kids um
one of the things I wanted to share with
you is sort of that personal experience
from the staff perspective that they are
uncomfortable situations to be in right
um that that we certainly want to
protect kids and when staff show up to
these events um it it is it doesn't feel
good right like nobody wants to engage
in them so the more clarity from
practice from technical assistance from
the department and from legislation when
the rsa's come out is really helpful for
us from a practice Point um just so that
we know how to act in these certain
situations so the one thing that I did
kind of want to share related to the
surveillance and for consideration from
the committee in any future legislation
is to provide some of that guidance
around those things um and to consider
student dignity component so I think one
of the things when I read that initially
that I thought was um you know a lot of
kids being on social media and things
like that like them creating their
digital footprint and what would that
look like for kids moving forward right
like when you're in when you're seven
years old and you're having a hard day
and something like this happens who sees
that how is that shared what is the
intent of that surveillance um the same
way that the report that we have to now
fill out based off of the legislation
changes last year that report is
maintained in-house in districts um it
was written um and developed by the
Department of Education but we don't we
don't send those reports to the
Department of Education currently we
maintain them in our local school
districts and they can be requested by
the Department of Education for review
but they're filled out at the building
level and then shared at the district
level so that we're aware of what
occurred and we can make plans to
prevent it from happening in the future
but one of the things I think that would
be important is who sees those um Visual
and audio things what are the what's the
intent of that if it's simply to um hold
people accountable like at a higher
level like you know being watched so
you're going to behave a certain way
that's one thing but if we're actually
going to use that data to make decisions
I think one of the things that you're
most concerned with is how does that
transpire so there's two pieces right
like is the kid um hurt you want to have
documentation of whether or not anyone
gets hurt and I think cameras would
accomplish that but it I don't know if
cameras are going to catch the how did
it start part why did we get their part
and so if that's the piece that you're
trying to Target I do think the only way
to do that would be to have cameras
everywhere all the time and then all
those other pieces that you brought up
um would be things you'd want to
consider so I think the intent of the
cameras is something to consider what is
the aim of it there and then making
decisions and telling us kind of what
you want to see happen from that point
Thank You representative Gibbons yeah I
think it's from my P from my
understanding it's all of the above that
they want to they want to
see if they're being properly used if
the escalation is being used prior to
and then also the documentation on if
anyone excuse me if anyone got hurt like
all those points that you brought up I
think is the intention
so thank you representative disimon
thank you and I think that your
reference to the 91a um is is very
important so any legislation that can be
written um can be written in such a
manner as to be sure that none of that
information is available to anyone other
than the staff necessary to help that
child with their education process so I
I think that's a very important point
and I thank you for bringing that
up thank you thank you very much all
right anyone
else come on down sir
thank you hello myby app turn on
your my name's Toby islen um I
appreciate you taking the uh time to
listen to my thoughts on the subject I
also like to say I'm nervous I've never
done this before so um I do have um just
uh some thoughts that I had put down on
paper to submit in writing if that's
okay but uh also just um addressing a
little bit of my background and why I'm
care about this matter um I am I'm from
malor New Hampshire I have kids in the
public school system very invested in
that I've also spent my professional
career working with students with
emotional and behavioral disabilities um
for the past 18 years um working with
children who come from very very
difficult circumstances and are
exhibiting some some really unsafe
Behavior towards them um themselves and
others over the last 18 years um as um
best practices have changed have changed
I've seen really wonder positive
movements in changes of practices and
training uh trauma-informed training um
ways to deescalate situations to
mitigate and avoid the use of restraint
um and and seclusion um that being said
what's been stated here there are
circumstances where there is that
imminent threat to self or others where
somebody's going to get seriously hurt
or at times um somebody's life is on the
line such as a kid running into traffic
um trying to hurt thems or kill
themselves that restraints are sometimes
necessary um I work in a residential
school uh with boys uh for with boys
with emotional and behavioral
disabilities and um we our main goal is
to reduce and eliminate the use of
restraint it's an agency Mission it's
our schools mission to do this and we
have committees set up for it and we're
regularly reviewing what we can do to
reduce and eliminate the use of
restraints um I also want to state that
they we do um as far as the oversight
and Reporting requirements um part of it
is we do need to have an administrator
review of every time there is a
restraint and seclusion that we do and
document it every time there is a use of
restraint and seclusion the student is
checked out by the nurse um uh to to
document any injuries and note that so
if there is any nit checking to see if
anything improper was done and those
pieces of it are following through um we
are meeting regularly with the staff
members um after a a hold to see what we
could have done differently what are we
going to do NE next time to reduce it
and eliminate it um some of the the the
fears that I have if we make it more
difficult for educators to to handle
unsafe behaviors is what happens to
students if schools do take a hands-off
approach over the years we've had many
students come to us in a resident plac
residentially with us because the school
districts they they go to have taken
away the ability for staff to utilize
restraint techniques that means the
students who might have been held once
or twice in a public school are going to
be placed residentially in an outof
District placement that is no longer the
least restrictive environment in
manyways because they don't need
residential for other reasons except the
school district is unable to handle
their behaviors if this goes further
more to um other like residential
facilities too and and our ability to
Keep Kids Safe um it it is uh is
hampered then there's more likelihood
for students to be sent out of state um
further removing them from their
communities and ways to get back home we
have a student right now he's he's a
young man who's been struggling for
years and that's the question like can
he stay in state or can he go out of
state due to the unsafe behaviors and
something that that we're working with
to develop ways we're having meetings
all the time what can we do trying
different stuff um having observ and
interventions and assessments to what
else can we do to reduce the use of
restraint because the next step is going
away where he's not going to be able to
see his mom every weekend like he
currently does and how long is he going
to be out of state so there there is
that piece about what can we do to also
keep kids as close to communities that
um I really feel passionate about and
important for kids as well I know that
we have gotten kids um who from from
like theyve been placed out of New
Hampshire in other in other states
because of their behaviors are so
extreme that even out of District
placements in New Hampshire are unable
to work with them safely there's a lot
of really on like I think New Hampshire
has done a really good job with some of
the oversight and the laws that they've
been put into place to um Keep Kids Safe
and that's not true in every state and
we've seen a lot of situations where
kids are coming back to us where they
were placed out of District put in
really unsafe situations where they
experienced a lot of
trauma because their behaviors weren't
able to be kept safe in New Hampshire so
I I hope that as legislation is being
considered some of those some of those
aspects are considered and would really
I I mean I welcome oversight some of the
really positive things that have come
over the last couple of years that are
initially a little nerve-wracking you
know being an administrator in a school
working with kids who are exhibiting
unsafe behaviors are the oversight of
the disability um Advocates coming in um
and interviewing kids they come in
regularly and they interview any kid
who's willing to talk to them they ask
them about restraints how they're
utilized if they're utilized properly
it's a private conversation between them
without our staff there for that
oversight to ensure that kids voices are
heard and they do have the ability to
talk to somebody um if if they do feel
like anything improper has happened so
um I do welcome oversight as much as
possible with also understanding that
some of the behaviors and the mental
health issues that kids are struggling
with um these days is is pretty profound
and um disturbing and many cases because
you really feel for these kids that are
unable to keep themselves safe and are
trying to harm themselves and
others thank you very much it sounds
like you're doing fantastic work thank
you so much um are you using a
prescribed methodology evidence-based
yes that and is that something that you
can speak to is is it Dr Green program
or something similar so in order to all
staff who engage in um any restraint
techniques who go Hands-On and all sta
it's our policy that all staff are
trained in it are trained in right now
we're um work with a Crisis Prevention
Institute for nonviolent um Crisis
Intervention as well as uh TCI training
um so those are the the trainings that
our staff have and they all have
extensive um deescalation and Trauma
informed training as a part of them in
fact that's the majority of both
trainings are ways to reduce be
proactive um to ensure that students um
are being taught competencies of how to
deescalate staff are taught competencies
on how to deescalate to mitigate those
I've been um a a trainer for CPI for I
think 12 years now it's changed
dramatically since I first became a a
licensed trainer where the as far as
where the focus when I first started was
on how to restrain students and keep
them safe over the last um decade it's
moved into trauma-informed approach
where almost the entire like the most of
the training it's expanded a length of
time where it used to be 8 hours now
it's 22 hours as far as the training
goes um and the majority of that is
focused on trauma informed care and how
to deescalate situations and then how to
repair situations and Learn and Grow
from them if a situation does occur yes
they do teach how to and then another
emphasis has been put on um
disengagement techniques so if a student
is unsafe and they are attacking a staff
what can you do first to try to deflect
the blow or the strike try to uh take
away objects in the room that to make it
safe so really focusing on all ways to
reduce um the need to restrain in in
safer ways before going Hands-On because
the the and the and that goes with the
law in New Hampshire is it really is
imminent risk to Serious bodily injury
to sell for others so that doesn't mean
throw a pencil at you that means serious
bodily injury means somebody could have
to go a hospital for a broken bone or
something like it at the very least so
it is and and that's changed a lot and
so the focus on the training has changed
significantly they're re um I have to
get recertified as a trainer every two
years and every two years they're upping
the training and it's different for the
best practices and techniques that
they're using um not only to update the
holds to try to make them ensure that
they're not traumatic cuz some of them
when I first started they're different
and so they're uh then they were and
they say that could be traumatic for
some individuals so they're making those
adjustments both to the holding
techniques but also the proactive
deescalation techniques and then also
the the followup to prevent it from
happening in the future and the the the
training and learning that occurs and
that's true of the TCI training that we
also utilize however um I'm not the
trainer for that well thank you thank
you very much uh for the record uh could
you spell your last name for me yes i s
l i
n okay very good and would you be
willing to just hang back uh briefly
after we um adjourn so I can talk to you
a bit more sounds like what you're doing
is is wonderful it's what we're looking
for and we're always looking for ways to
improve so again that's the thing as far
as legislation goes I welcome
legislation that can provide more
oversight and ways to continue to move
forward because I think you said it best
like we've come a long ways but we still
have a long way to go I think you said
that and and we're learning all the time
um there are just a one pie on the
cameras that I don't know what the best
answer is for this but I do I did want
to say that we have you know students
who have a lot of that guilt and shame a
lot of the time they don't want their
pictures taken one of the things that we
do at our school is we do something
called Sparkling moments every week
where we um capture students in the
moment doing stuff that's fun so that we
can put it into a report and send it to
their fam so like their their
residentially place they don't see them
all the time see what they're doing in
the classroom what they're doing in the
wood shop what they're doing like
catching a fish or go row boating and
that sort of thing to see them in the
moment what they're doing there's some
students who we can't take their
pictures because they feel so much they
they they will escalate really quickly
and become unsafe we've had students who
have come to us from other facilities
that do have cameras in place and the
students have talked about how they're
so relieved that we don't because of the
trauma and shame that they felt that's
not across the board many of our
students love to have their pictures
taken many of our students let love all
of that and would love but I just that
that as far as a consideration that
there are some students that to that
dignity shame embarrassment peace or for
whatever reason really don't want their
picture taken their audio recorded
Etc representative Gibbons you had a
question or comment I did but he but he
touched on it so so we're good
representative Doone anything to add no
thank you very much all right and any
other
comments okay hearing none we have some
work to do so with that I guess we'll
adjourn and thank you very much for
being
here
e e